here was George Herbert Walker Bush when
he just turned 20 after risking his life
for his country on numerous bomber
missions he was shot down and rescued at
20 what was I doing at 20
[Music]
yeah I'm not what you call a poster boy
for heroism I have flat feet and would
give you up for a slice of pound cake
now it's easy to draw comparisons
between then and now 16 million
Americans fought in World War two today
16 million people watch this everything
yeah Rita yeah now that's no dig at now
it's just to point out a connection
between two eras that all of our
entertainment and leisure time was
enabled by the bravery of people you
might never have met if you have one of
the 16 million in your clan I salute you
you're lucky they made my idiocy
possible to quote John Kerry in a tweet
that he sent to me happy Veterans Day
Greg I'm glad that all of us who served
in uniform fought to defend your freedom
to be a complete fool on Twitter
down-and-out for once the driftwood
Dracula was right the only reason why I
can be a fool today is because someone
was a hero yesterday so thanks John to
quote one of your special friends
[Music]
you've got to do is go and I'll be there
[Music]
when he had hair looking back is sweet
but the price of nostalgia is forgetting
the present today brave men and women do
outstanding work protecting you and me
our military law enforcement border
police and patrol so do not mistakenly
believe this is a generation of video
gaming sofa surfers fact is men and
women die every day for this country
although at times it's hard to remind
yourself that the rest of us aren't all
idiots
check out this tweet from Slate about
Bush's service-dog quote Sully HW Bush
is a service dog who had been with the
president for six months not his
lifelong companion now imagine being
that writer questioning whether Bush's
dog deserved all that attention yep
today I'm gonna put that mutt in its
place excuse me lifelong companion Sully
isn't 94 years old that's late sorry
slate Sully can't feel your hot take
like the rest of the world he doesn't
read Slate he could but he doesn't he's
a dog a smart dog well for one more day
you were a rat a silly silly rat
meanwhile others in the media kept an
eagle eye on Trump my god what was up
with his jacket he walks into the
National Cathedral the other presidents
are seated he is wearing his overcoat he
takes it off and hands said crumpled
overcoat to the young marine officer who
was acting as his escort what's going on
there why didn't he just leave the coat
the overcoat in the back of the seat I
kind of hand it to Brian always focusing
on the big picture
when he isn't busy making up crap I'm
surprised I didn't say he was there
while looking at the footage you can't
see me but I'm right behind Trump
they're so obsessed with Trump though
they missed the coolest thing you got to
check this beard out you see this beard
coming imagine what you could hide in
that beard I could hide in that beard
that's an Oak Ridge boy by the way I
could hide in there for weeks meanwhile
others use the funeral as another excuse
to trash the president what's really
going on right now is a national
reaction to Trump no matter what we say
or don't say it's a reaction to what we
have and we miss the better we missed
that part of decency and honor thanks
Chris
he's more off-base than a drunk
shortstop here's a Washington Post
headline at President Bush's funeral
Trump sits with fellow presidents but
still stands alone obviously that's a
lie even I can't stand and sit at the
same time and so even at a time of
reverence and unity they miss the point
in obsess on their obsession
if only Trump's head would sprout horns
spin around and spew fire but will you
expect if Trump didn't go he'd get
slammed he does go he gets slammed
what's really ironic about all of this
what did these funerals celebrate most
when you thought of mr. Bush what did
you think most about patriotism duty
family faith isn't that the stuff that's
openly mocked
today by pop culture the media academia
there are more people who believe the
earth is flat then believe in anything
and yet this week those were the things
that mattered weird isn't it when you're
looking at death you're not thinking
about identity or jacket or the resume
of a service pet I hope we've learned
something I mean think about this
President George Herbert Walker Bush
fought in World War two
he flew 58 combat missions he was shot
down rescued Benni turned 21
think about that later he ran the CIA
helped end the Cold War and rescued
Kuwait from Iraq yet in 1992 he still
lost to Bill Clinton just as Bob Dole
did four years later why because his
amazing life put him at a certain age no
war heroes please we'll take that young
philanderer we thought it over and
decided so the same people who make
shallow decisions about you made one
about him you just got a laugh that's
the other big message here Bush was
funny here's proof it's the last
statement I'm gonna have on broccoli
there are truckloads of broccoli at this
very minute descending on Washington my
family is divided I do not like broccoli
and I haven't liked it since I was a
little kid and my mother made me eat it
and I'm President of the United States
and I'm not gonna eat any more broccoli
when we talk
when we talk about vanishing heroism
don't forget vanishing humor humor is
what holds this whole operation
civilization together the only way to
celebrate hate though is to shame censor
humor from the world jokes connect
connect people so eliminate them and we
won't be falling on the floor laughing
we'll just be falling on the floor it's
why the real heroes don't just fight
communism and Hitler but also people who
can't take a damn joke
those humorless creeps seem to be
everywhere and reproducing so as we gain
that kind of noxious non hero we lose
men like Bush according to the
Department of Veteran Affairs roughly
four hundred ninety six thousand seven
hundred seventy seven American veterans
were estimated to still be alive as of
September 2018 what's that tell you
they're still here a half a million of
them they're not making more and we
should make it a point to talk with them
learn from them and share a laugh with
them because this week we lost at least
one and we're gonna lose more and that
friends is no joke
let's welcome tonight's yes he's more
country than a mud flap made of daisy
dukes from the duo Big & Rich singer and
songwriter John rude jokes where smokes
he'd be the Marlboro Man comedian Jimmy
Fela like jacket the co hostess with the
mostess National Review reporter Kat Tim
he's responsible for most solar eclipses
former WWE Superstar my massive sidekick
and host of unpeel Fox Nation Tyrus
thank you thank you
I loved how you're dressed today yes I'm
not talking about you an extra from New
Kids on the Block your Yura came in the
holiday spirit well I did it's Merry
Christmas time yes it is I would just
like to give a shout-out to my 86 year
old granny rich mmm who watches your
show she smokes a pack of Marlboro Reds
every single day drinks drinks a little
whiskey every night still pulls a
40-hour a week and she made this jacket
and the jeans Wow so what what you're
saying is if I smoke a pack of
cigarettes and drink a lot of booze I
could become an excellent seamstress
it's possible it's possible actually I
wrote a song about my grandfather who's
a world war two vet he was in the
Pacific he was a tunnel rat hmm so he's
a little guys about 115 he joined at 17
a lot about his age so we could go fight
and we've heard a lot of those stories
he had six Purple Hearts and he went
over to the Pacific and fought and I
wrote a song about him called the good
Lord and the man and on George Bush's
85th birthday I sang that song but I
missed him because he was jumping out of
an airplane over there for the birthday
and then he called me back and I was on
a stage playing a bigger rich concert
and he left me this incredible voicemail
thanking me for the song and I'm so glad
that I missed this call because now I
have that message but that's true and
you played it for me I do it's real it's
real or it's Dana Carvey but the world
war two guys Greg they literally save
the world and
you know that there's less than a half a
million those guys left around if you
ever get a chance to see one of those
men shake their hand give him a big ol
hug say thank you for what you did for
our country
I mean Hitler was coming after us they
bombed Pearl Harbor they were coming
from both sides America stood up showed
its might and ran them off yeah that's
what happened Jimmy after talking about
the greatest generation how do you feel
about yourself good when I walked out of
the house today I actually walked like
feeling like a million bucks
and then I quoted like a longshot mirror
on the subway yeah I look like a
stripper who let himself go I mean I
call this look the tragic Mike this is
my tragedy but to your point I am scared
about us losing the greatest generation
because the country is going in a scary
direction where we are kind of an you
know incentivizing these kids to be
wusses and that's why I always think
like in New York it's kind of funny as a
cultural thing that will make fun of
what we would call southern rednecks
because that's like a stereotypical
thing to do but I thank God for them
because they're the only people raising
tough kids anymore like if Isis shows up
tomorrow you're not calling Hudson
hopper and Zane you're calling Bobby Jo
Bubba and Cletus and they're gonna take
Isis out using rifles they got for their
10th birthday that's how it's gonna go
down so I'm with I'm with mr. rich all
right cat thorny rich first of all I
just loved that photo of the service
service dog laying in front of the
casket yeah how dare anyone make fun of
that what is this person pinky because
daugh it's just like dogs are so great
like if I ever die yeah which I'm a my
cat would walk up and lay down next to
me but it would be to eat my face that's
a cat but I wouldn't mind I wouldn't be
using it anyway yes and you know what
it's almost like you're sacrificing
yourself yeah yeah I suppose yeah which
makes me almost a military hero I'm just
kidding I'm not I'm very grateful for
all the veterans because personally
based on the amount of anxiety I get
from like Jango
I couldn't go to war no neither I I'm as
bad as furthest from that as you could
be Tyrus thoughts I've like I said I
thought I was a it was a great week to
remember what's important in this
country I thought George Bush jr. his
speech on his father was powerful
amazing and it really I don't have a dad
but if I did I would hopefully talk
about him like that that was like well I
need to get one of those but might be
too late Wow they do all that Wow so it
was kind of cool and at the same time
like I did a lot of laughing like the
president if he doesn't go to the
funeral he's the worst man on the planet
yeah he goes to the funeral reaches over
and shakes the hand of an adversary yeah
classy move Obama classily shook his
hand back and he still was the worst man
in the world we just can't win with you
yeah it's just that was the story not
this amazing funeral that's time for
everyone to forget about divisions and
politics they still like no we need a
trump story what do you got well he did
shake hands with Obama that's all let's
do it run it I mean it's just where
we're at and it's shameful the other
thing I learned and we got to move on
but I about planning your own funeral
it's a lot of pressure and George Bush
he wrote half of his own of the plan I
have one page I came up with it don't
drop the ashes this will be on mine
throat don't drop the air says don't
invite anyone from maroon 5 yeah
open bar but no fancy drinks cuz I don't
like lines you know they should be
really quick and it should been a
weekday so you can take a day off
[Applause]